ballet lescar déteint sur antenne 2 dans
une demi heure ce sera la véritable
rentrée de l'ancien président à la
télévision
les israéliens contrôlent désormais tous
vers août claude cheysson s'est rendu
sur place
la mort de l'ancien ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères
l'ayatollah khomeini la des condamnés à
mort les chiffres du chômage léger mieux
pour moi dit bien que le nombre des
demandeurs d'emplois et d'encore
augmenter 1 messieurs bonsoir
l'événement politique de la semaine
cette antenne 2 qui va le créer dans
tout juste une demi heure avec notre
émission mensuelle l'heure de vérité
invité en effet de ce magazine présenté
par françois henri de virieu valéry
giscard d'estaing et c'est la première
fois que l'ancien président la
république s'exprimera en longueur à la
télévision depuis le 10 mai 81
vous connaissez le principe de
l'émission entretiens successifs avec
trois journalistes dont on ne connaît
pas encore les noms vous connaissez
aussi la vedette de la soirée mais
patricia charnelet nous rappelle le
contexte politique un peu spéciale de sa
présence
entre le rencontrant des siens il ya dix
jours valéry giscard d'estaing étaient
venus écouter ce qu'il a appelé les
aspirations des français
un test qui lui aura servi à préparer
des missions ce soir à tous ses
militants il a confié que le débat
politique devait s'élever et ils pensent
aujourd'hui que les français sont prêts
à l'entendre c'est donc la première fois
qu'un ex président vient expliquer le
rôle qu'il veut jouer je veux être utile
at il déjà dit une formule assez
générale qui peut autoriser toutes les
interprétations
il est vrai que la stratégie à suivre
est complexe il est vrai aussi que
l'ancien président a recueilli sur ce
sujet beaucoup d'avis contradictoires
souvent rendues publiques
c'est bien pourquoi il veut ce soir
s'expliquer lui-même pour éviter que
d'autres ne le fassent à sa plate
quant au message une parlera sans doute
de l'unité des français de la situation
économique reste enfin l'image l'aspect
plus personnel
comment at il digéré l'échec le succès
remporté par mi les giscardiens ne doit
pas lui faire oublier qu'ils se
retrouvent ce soir pour la première fois
depuis seize mois
face à l'opinion publique des réponses à
toutes ces questions à 20h35 le reste de
l'actualité politique après les
évènements du liban c'est que là bas la
situation évolue vite on peut maintenant
considéré que les israéliens contrôlent
toute la capitale
la voix du liban c'est à dire la radio
des phalangistes a annoncé en début
d'après midi que les miliciens de gauche
qui balaie avait cessé toute résistance
philippe rochot gelé phone
belém 83 ans la quasi totalité mais très
solitaire avec une première que j'aime
de clavier dans le cas du centre
commercial alors à l'écart des routes
ouest qu elles soient résistants à trois
heures auquel elles sont mortes et à la
mitrailleuse d'un fonds pourra tout
aussi les armes
il est trop loin sont alors entrés
femmes et les quelques et la cotisation
qui se ferait dans les abris et
orientale en russe pour qu'un brave est
alors les drapeaux blancs ne t'ai parlé
de résistance acharnée
bien que dd très bien et il est
actuellement retranché en cours d'année
au point d'entrée leur chapelle de
l'église et le camp de brancher et
pourtant tous deux encore ce soir dans
le secteur de l'hôpital barbir alors les
13e car connection dans certains y
mettent un peu du suspect mais 200
d'avoir le contrôle total de la
situation notamment à l'intérieur du
palestinien de tabac le plus grand camp
et la périphérie de beyrouth
l'ol paix a lancé un appel aux trois
pays de la force multinationale états
unis italie france et le liban viennent
demander une réunion d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
claude cheysson s'est rendu à beyrouth
dès ce matin pour renouveler les
condoléances de la france aux présidents
sarkis et réaffirmer les sentiments
d'amitié et de solidarité du président
mitterrand
il doit regagner paris dans les heures à
venir c'est un liban encore traumatisé
par l'assassinât de son président qu'il
a rencontré traumatisme très sensible
dans ces images impressionnantes de
l'enterrement de béchir gemayel hier
après-midi morizet artères c'est à
bickfaya dans la montagne libanaise en
secteur chrétiens berceau de la famille
gemayel a été inhumé hier le jeune
président de la république libanaise
élus en présence de sa femme de son père
de son frère et de milliers de libanais
qui manifestent leur désespoir
on entend des cris béchir relève toi
il n'y avait pas que les fidèles de
béchir gemayel les phalangistes
chrétiens pour participer au deuil du
liban et représentant des chrétiens de
gauche et des partis musulmans longtemps
adversaires des phalanges est elle un
peu aussi
dans ce pays divisé il n'est pas
impossible que la réconciliation se
fasse autour du cercueil de béchir
gemayel
voilà pour l'essentiel des informations
sur le liban aujourd'hui en iran c'est
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères sadek gonades et qui a été
exécuté la nuit dernière à téhéran
l'homme qui fut longtemps le porte
parole le gala de la de l'ayatollah
khomeini pardon alors en exil était
accusé d'avoir participé à un complot
contre le régime islamique régime
cannibale qui ne cessent de dévorer ses
propres terres publiques chatenet voici
sa des gonades et au moment où tous les
espoirs lui était permis aux côtés de
l'ayatollah communient dans l'avion du
retour triomphal à téhéran après presque
20 ans d'exil
aof le château götze année était l'un
des plus proches conseillers de communi
son fils spirituel du béton l'un des
stratèges de la lutte à distance contre
le chah ce 1er février 1979 comme eni
triomphe et avec lui sa des gonades et
son ascension sera fulgurante directeur
de la radio et la télévision membre du
conseil de la révolution ministre des
affaires étrangères il fait campagne ici
pour être élu président de la république
islamique battu par bani sadr ce sera
son premier échec
et puis la disgrâce aussi rapide que son
ascension
l' affaire des otages de l'ambassade
américaine google z et critique les
fanatiques religieux et les extrémistes
politiques
il est destitué et rapidement placé en
résidence surveillée
enfin la chute le 10 avril dernier gods
et des arrêtés accusés d'avoir comploté
contre les mam il fait ses aveux
télévisés depuis trois mois dit il j'ai
préparé le renversement du régime est
envisagé de tuer l'imam et les
principaux dirigeants du pays dès lors
son destin était scellé condamné à mort
après trois jours de procès il a été
fusillé à la prison des villes dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi une nouvelle
fois la révolution cannibale a tué l'un
de ses fils voilà l'instant et un coup
de téléphone michel meyer noteront et
spéciale à bonn crise ouverte en
allemagne puisque helmut schmidt le
chancelier ouest allemand vient de
proposer au chef de l'opposition helmut
kohl et au président de la république
fédérale allemande car seules des
élections anticipées à certaines
conditions l'attend un discours très
important du chancelier pour demain
matin deux attentats contre des
diplomates koweïtiens à l'étranger à
madrid et à karachi on ignore pour
l'instant
la nature des liens entre les deux actes
le président guinéen à l'elysée
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
l'indépendance de ce pays qui fut le
premier de toutes les nations africaines
à le demander il y a près d'un quart de
siècle
le numéro un guinéen au pouvoir sékou
touré à conakry depuis cette époque
répondent ainsi à une invitation du chef
de l'état et un voyage de son
prédécesseur là bas il ya quatre ans
paul nahon revient de conakry c'est un
portrait très étonnant qu'ils nous
proposent du président cet ouvrage de
vous aimeriez vous que l'histoire
colporte et les dire
c'est un homme qui a été au service de
son peuple un homme qui a aimé la vérité
qu'il a pratiqué l homme qui n'a eu peur
que de dieu et du peuple mais pas des
roms voilà ce que j'ai fait
oui
ahmed sékou touré la firme souvent il
faut maintenir la dictature du peuple
pour le peuple
cet homme de 60 ans est l'une des
grandes figures de l'afrique un
révolutionnaire qui en son temps s'est
opposé à la france
en disant non au général de gaulle
c'était il ya 25 ans sékou touré
proclamé l'indépendance immédiate de la
guinée est isolé son pays pendant
plusieurs années
le président guinéen se jette alors à
corps perdu dans la lutte anti
impérialiste et dans le non-alignement
ses héros deviennent très vite à son
image d homme exerçant sur le peuple
une dictature sans fans ici dans son
palais présidentiel sékou touré nous
avait invités à visionner sur un écran
géant de télévision
un film sur l'un de ses modèles le
président de la corée du nord kim il
sung
la guinée c'est d'abord une économie en
faillite dépendante de l'étranger pour
son alimentation
la guinée c'est ensuite un sous sol qui
renferme d'immenses richesses en bauxite
en fer en uranium
à tel point que sékou touré par lui-même
de scandale géologique et pourtant la
guinée reste l'un des pays les plus
pauvres d'afrique
sous couvert de la lutte anti
impérialiste armée de sékou touré
gouverne seul faisant peu à peu le vide
autour de lui
ils dénoncent les complots réels ou
imaginaires pour justifier la chasse aux
opposants
les emprisonnements et les exécutions
amnesty international dénonçait 178 2000
à 4000 prisonniers politiques en guinée
nous avons toujours respecté les droits
du peuple et les droits de l'homme et je
crois que la démocratie le système
démocratique guinéen est en avance sur
la plupart des thèmes démocratique en
europe
pis le président c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
ici en guinée dans votre pays une
certaine libéralisation depuis deux ans
mais les rapports d'amnesty
international que vous connaissez
continue d'affirmer qu'il y a plusieurs
milliers de prisonniers politiques dans
les prisons
voyez l'aiment chaud les jeux super
temps dans l'air et des personnes là il
ya des témoignages monsieur le président
témoignage de qui des gens torturés des
syndicalistes des ouvriers vous avait
été calé vous contestez en glory et qui
on a voulu on en veut à la guinée pour
avoir dit non
rozehnal des gaules au moment du
référendum la guinée a assumé ses
responsabilités en toute conscience et
cette situation singulière a été
exploitée dans le but d'isoler la guinée
monsieur le président alors quel est le
but concret de votre voyage à paris
votre visite officielle en france
vous attendez quoi de la france mettant
concrètement les entend d'abord définir
la disponibilité totale de la guinée à
coopérer sincèrement avec la france dans
tous les domaines où il peut être
possible d'associer les intérêts de la
france et sur la guinée
qu'est ce que vous faites avec toulon
choir blanc là
blanc est le fils distinctif
c'est votre signe oui
le connaître à leur table et qu'on vous
le sortez dans la rue
vous savez les gens comme ça ouais ouais
bien qu'on voit le mont tremblant
une nouvelle fois le numéro un guinéen
rejeté à son arrivée les accusations
d'atteintes aux droits de l'homme dans
son pays et pourtant au moment même où
ils étaient reçus à l'elysée les
familles françaises de huit prisonniers
disparus en guinée ont lâchés dans le
ciel de paris des ballons multicolores
portant le nom de chacun d'entre eux
dont tout porte à croire sékou touré
nous le disait lui-même qu'ils ont été
exécutés
un certain trouble d'ailleurs s'est
manifestée chez les députés socialistes
réunis en journée parlementaire les
députés sont partagés sur l'opportunité
de cette visite que lionel jospin
premier secrétaire du parti considère
comme normale compte rendu du reste de
cette journée
jean-michel mercurol satisfaction
générale sur la politique économique
mais regret de certains de ne pas être
encore assez écoutés par le gouvernement
et même parfois désaccord sur la
politique fiscale
voilà en résumé le climat qui a prévalu
au cours de cette première journée
parlementaire socialiste jacques delors
laurent fabius pierre bérégovoy sont
venus à l'écouté des parlementaires
comme pour mesurer l'effet concret de la
politique économique vécue sur le
terrain
la plupart des députés socialistes
venaient de passer à mouiller de dans
leur circonscription optimisme à cause
des résultats déjà obtenus par le
gouvernement en matière d' indice des
prix par exemple et optimisme nuancée
par rapport à certaines orientations
notamment en matière de budget et de
justice fiscale
nous sommes d'accord pour la rigueur
mais faites nous le plus de social
possible disait l'un à force de faire
plaisir à nos ennemis en risque de
désespérer nos amis disent elles aussi
sont optimistes mais ils sont rentrés
conscient de toutes les difficultés que
nous rencontrons
il ya des forces considérables en
particulier dans le domaine économique
qui s'opposent à etsaut notre programme
qui s'opposent à des mesures de justice
fiscale
ils savent que des concessions sont
faites à ces forces politiques
économiques
il souhaite que ces concessions
n'avaient pas trop loin et est la
politique pour laquelle nous avons été
élus soit prochainement entre le
suivisme et la surenchère vis-à-vis du
gouvernement
le groupe socialiste doit donc trouver
son chemin alors justement autres
journées parlementaires celle du pc le
pc qui critique un certain nombre de
projets gouvernementaux récent prix dit
il
sous la pression de la droite et du
patronat vient d'être annoncée qui
autorise par exemple les propriétaires
d'entreprise est haïe d'honneur et de
l'impôt sur la fortune
s'il annonce l'investissement dans les
quatre années à venir ça ne nous
apparaît très généreux d'autant plus que
nous n'avons pas la garantie que ces
investissements soient créateurs
d'emplois en tout cas ses
investissements dans quatre ans vous
savez ça fait un délit un peu long et
nous disons en tout cas que ça ne fait
que renforcer la proposition nous avons
en fait d'une nouvelle tranche de
l'impôt sur la fortune sous 2 milliard
et demi lancers francs pour que cet
impôt ne soit pas vidé de son contenu
la succession des déclarations de
responsables du parti communiste est pas
un peu une sorte de mise en garde
visiblement comme en ont dû à la
succession est une succession comme vous
avez pu le remarquer très équilibré tout
ce que nous avons dit à la fête de
l'humanité ce qu on dit ce matin les
parlementaires communistes
ce sont des propos très responsable très
responsable mais qui tiennent à faire
respecter les orientations sur lesquels
la gauche a été élu en mai 1980 le pc
faisait allusion à l'exonération de
l'impôt sur la fortune la cgt elle
faisait de même hier le patronat ayant
vous le savez plutôt bien accueilli
cette décision du conseil des ministres
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement pour un chef d'entreprise
et bien c'est roselyne koskas qui nous
le dit à l'aide d'un exemple
c'est une pme ordinaire comme il en
existe encore des centaines dans la
région parisienne harry ouest une
entreprise de construction familiale
comme il se doit
fondée il ya quelque 40 ans par emile
boutillon acquis succès de son fils
xavier un jeune patron qui possède
quelques biens personnels bien sûr mais
surtout son entreprise de 150 personnes
est une valeur officielle de 25 millions
de francs
jusqu'à hier l'impôt sur la fortune
coûté à xavier boutillon 330 mille
francs une somme importante que les
bénéfices de son entreprise ne lui
permettait pas de payer
j'étais obligé de vendre quelque chose
vous devant des actions ou je sais pas
mais c'était quasiment infernale alors
qu'aujourd'hui je peux établir un projet
d'investissement et un projet
d'amélioration de rentabilité qui va
nous permettre d'espérer développer la
maison dans les années qui viennent vous
juger comment l'impôt sur la fortune
jusqu'ici
l'impôt sur la fortune et peut-être
juste mais sur l'outil de travail c'est
impossible c'est impensable au moins à
ce taux là c'est impensable de demander
une entreprise fait qu'un individu paye
un et demi pour cent après paiement de
tous les impôts soit 4 et demi pour cent
de rentabilité pour les entreprises la
plupart ne sont pas donc le set
infiniment trop élevé sinon toujours
apporté une pourquoi pas
l'accueil de la bourse aux décisions
d'hier a été bon les valeurs françaises
ont gagné près de 2% ce matin les
chiffres du chômage toujours en hausse
mais l'augmentation du nombre des
demandeurs d'emplois s'est ralenti cela
donne très précisément en données
corrigées des variations saisonnières
2 millions 49 mille 600 demandeurs
d'emploi léger mieux donc mais le
ministre jean le garrec évite de crier
victoire
la rentrée d'andré bergeron aujourd'hui
à la mutualité le leader de force
ouvrière c'est surtout déclarait inquiet
pour la survie de la politique
contractuelle inquiet aussi pour la
sortie du blocage et surtout dire au
gouvernement c'est que 1 %
d'augmentation de salaire ça pèse des
fois beaucoup plus qu'un pour cent de
salaire en dans le domaine des
équilibres nécessaires de la société
démocratique
or ce que je redoute c'est je dirais la
danse la tradition de tension de toute
nature qui peuvent surgir non seulement
dans le milieu des salariés mais
également dans d'autres catégories socio
professionnelles comme nous l'avons vu
d'ailleurs ces jours ci voilà le compris
de citroën à aulnay sous bois on vient
de me faire savoir que la maîtrise a
finalement décidé de ne plus bloquer à
nouveau à partir de demain la production
pour protester comme elle le faisait
depuis trois jours contre la présence de
l'ouvrier tenus pour responsables de
violences le contremaître blessé a écrit
au président de la république je veux
at-il dit exercer mon travail dans la
dignité
réactions des milieux politiques à la
mutation de bernard langlois notre
confrère qui présentait jusqu'à lors le
journal antenne 2010 une semaine sur
deux mutations comme grand reporter aux
informations générales la demande de
pierre desgraupes le pdg d'antenne 2 est
considéré par la rédaction comme une
sanction
il s'agissait d'une décision prise à la
suite de l'annoncé de la mort de la
princesse grèce par berlin
langlois première réaction donc celle du
gué de bouchardeau pour le ps eut qui
juge la sanction inquiétante à
séparation des grands moyens
audiovisuels avec l'état devrait l
amener les dirigeants des chaînes à
endosser lé comportement frileux et
diplomatique que l'on reproché hier au
gouvernement demande la secrétaire
national du psu quant à la délégation
parlementaire pour la radio télévision
française à l'assemblée nationale elle a
manifesté son étonnement et l'un de ses
membres le socialiste françois loncle a
qualifié la mutation de bernard langlois
d'un digne d' injustifiée et d'un
conclut un petit regard au studio 4 si
nous avons des images en provenance du
débat qui va se dérouler tout à l'heure
avec valéry giscard d'estaing qui sera
n'est pas encore arrivé il est en train
de se faire maquiller me dit dont il
sera interrogé par trois journalistes
débat animé par françoise vialle yeux à
20h35 tout de suite après journée
toujours rien de nouveau dans l enquête
sur l'accident de la princesse grace les
monégasques eux rendent depuis ce matin
dernier hommage à leur princesse pour
ses obsèques samedi claude cheysson
danielle mitterrand est un très grand
nombre de personnalités de la politique
et du spectacle seront là antenne 2
retransmettra la cérémonie à 11 heures
samedi donc deux gendarmes tués à coups
de fusil en dordogne à saint-astier ce
double meurtre serait le fait d'un
déséquilibré
l'alcool tue un français toutes les 27
minutes voilà le chiffre accusateurs
contenues dans un rapport adressé par le
professeur jean bernard au président la
république
et puis du nouveau pour lui assurer en
matière d'accidents de la route à
l'initiative d'une compagnie ils
pourront s'ils le veulent bénéficier et
s'ils roulent peu de tarifs réduits
vous ne parcourez pas plus de 9000 km
par an avec votre automobile
ce petit compteur poser sur votre moteur
l'une de lumière par un garagiste agréé
peut vous réserver de bonnes surprises
lors de votre visite chez votre assureur
limité de l'appareil
branché sur la sortie de boîte de
vitesses
et l'autre sortie
brancher directement sur le peuple de
conteur
qui est à la voiture le pape de
compteurs des tableaux de bord ce qui
fait que le kilométrage qui est indiquée
au tableau de bord et le kilométrage qui
est indiqué aux comptes aux la
différence entre les deux représentent
le kimono kilomètres parcourus dans
l'année puisque le relevé annuel de
l'avantagé de ce système pour l'usager
est avant tout un avantage financier
puisque notre contrat prévoit qu'en
contrepartie la limitation de 9000
kilomètres l'usager peut parcourir tous
les ans notre tarif est inférieur
d'environ 30 à 50% par rapport au tarif
classique en cette période d'économie
l'auto km devrait intéresser au moins un
automobiliste sur trois en france
un détail intéressant ça pose ne coûte
rien initiative d'une grande compagnie
d'assurances il n'est pas tout à fait
ouvert à tous
le client devra avoir entre 25 et 60
disant posséder son permis de conduire
depuis deux années et n'avoir provoqué
aucun accident durant cette période des
réserves qui parait-il le concerne
statistiquement cas minimum
d'automobilistes petits consommateurs de
kilomètres or maintenant pas de grandes
surprises nationale henri leconte jérôme
potier thierry tulasne et yannick noah
se sont qualifiés pour les demi finales
pour ceux d'entre vous qui suivent
événements à la télévision et pour ceux
surtout qui ont dévoré avec passion les
images de flushing meadow une
interrogation pourquoi tant de grands et
de moyens a mis les réponses que va nous
donner maintenant
gérard holtz jimmy connors joue et gagne
avec un normal
ivan lendl jouer pair avec un
intermédiaire john mcenroe ajouté tombe
avec un plastique guillermo vilas
retourne élite avec 1 a grandi chez les
français yannick noah numéro un on a un
moyen gilles moreton lui on a un grand
débit d'art évidemment je voulais parler
des raquettes et en particulier des
tamis de ses joueurs professionnels le
tamis je vous le rappelle c'est cette
partie de la raquette de tennis et si
vous êtes un technicien avisé
vous devez savoir qu'il ya au moins
trois points importants dans une
raquette il y a le centre géométrique du
cordage il y a le sweet spot on le
centre de percussion il y a également le
lieu de vibrations c'est l'endroit dans
la raquette de tennis où les vibrations
sont nulles et l'idéal c'est de faire
coïncider ces trois points alors restons
simples ce qu'ont voulu faire les
techniciens en agrandissant le tamis
c'est d'agrandir la zone d'impact est
donc d'améliorer le contrôle de la balle
cette raquette m'apporter d'abord
beaucoup plus de contrôle
beaucoup plus de une vitesse de base
supérieur avec moins d'effort
la seule chose
le seul problème c'est un peu un
problème d'adaptation parce que ça
change bien évidemment je jouais avec un
modèle j'ai joué avec le même modèle
pendant six ans et donc il m'a fallu un
petit moment d'adaptation mais au bout
d'un mois j'étais complètement à la clé
je pense que c'est une raquette qui
apporte beaucoup à tous les joueurs et à
tous les niveaux on s'aperçoit que
maintenant dans les 100 premiers ya à
peu près 80 joueurs qui jouent avec soin
tamis intermédiaire soit un grand ami et
je pense que d'ici quelques temps tout
le monde jouera avec un grand ami et on
s'est beaucoup moqué du premier champion
qui a osé jouer avec un grand ami jean
meyer de don ici en pull bleu contre
mcenroe depuis plus personne ne rit
mcenroe d'ailleurs devraient peut-être
s'y mettre lui aussi pour borg s'est
déjà fait pourquoi en effet se priver
d'une raquette qui peut aider à mieux
jouer du champion aux débutants tout le
monde vient de le comprendre
selon certaines statistiques d'ailleurs
sur sans raquette vendu l'an mieux 59
seraient des moyens tamic 16 des grands
amis développement commercial prodigieux
et les fabricants qui voit grand jure qu
un tel succès est dans leurs cordes
les résultats du kart et il fallait
jouer le 7 le 2 le vin et le 12 où il ya
le 10 et le 12 la ja contestation
j'espère que ça va être réglé d'ici la
fin de ce journal dans l'ordre vous
pouvez vous le voyez emporte l'empocher
73 mille franc qui suit son traitement
de frais dans un ordre différent 4500
francs
enfin la mort du plus grand violoniste
français christian ferras ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas 50 ans avec figues dumez
maintenant la météo prodomaines oui et
le temps est toujours beau et chaud en
tout cas sur la majorité du pays avec
une petite tendance aux brouillards
matinaux dans l'est et dans le centre de
la france mais ils vont très vite
disparaître pour laisser la place à un
grand beau soleil cependant la france
s'est coincé entre un anticyclone au
nord de l'allemagne et une dépression à
l'ouest du portugal ce qui va nous
amener un flux de vent chaud par le sud
provoquant probablement une tendance
orageuse d'abord dans le sud-ouest et
ensuite cette tendance va ça va aller
jusqu'au sud de la bretagne donc un très
beau temps un petit risque d'orage
également dans les actes mairie
un de très grave en tout cas les
températures seront toujours très élevé
pour la saison 26 à 28 degrés dans le
nord 28 30 degrés dans le centre et 30
32 degrés dans le sud avec 28 degrés
dans la corse vous voyez de température
tout à fait confortable pour la saison
le soleil se lève à 7h 30 et une pour se
coucher à 19h59 et c'est là sa renault a
pour le quarté s'était moqué avez raison
c'est pas la machine c'était donc le 7
le 2 le vin et le 12 pour ceux d'entre
vous qui l'ont joué prochain rendez-vous
avec l'actualité 23h15
hervé claude mais tout de suite après
journal après une page de publicité
valéry giscard d'estaing dans notre
émission l'heure de vérité va la vie sur
les cinq qui s'entretient pour l'instant
avec françois henri de virieu bonsoir à
tous à demain 20 heures